a tiny woman against the hulking alien
nightmare a cgi bear that looks
absolutely unbearable some breadheads
are really gunning for prey
by far the biggest complaint among fans
is the controversial redesign of the
predator which portrays the creature in
a decidedly more monstrous form than
we're used to dubbed the feral predator
it's an ancestor to the bees seen
fighting arnold schwarzenegger's dutch
in the original film 300 years after the
events of prey director dan trachtenberg
told digital spy i wanted to make this
version of the predator so much more
feral and ferocious and animalistic from
its movements to its silhouettes and its
design while trachtenberg's explanation
makes sense some predator fans have
responded negatively to the new look
which is revealed during an action scene
midway through the film you don't need
to look further than the comments
section of the fan website avp galaxy to
see the disdain many have for the design
for instance one user said carol's
weapons were interesting and it was fun
watching him on screen my one gripe is
that it wasn't crazy about the face
redesign it was just okay for me similar
sentiments appear in various comment
circles across the web though the new
look does have several fans one user is
quoted as saying prey is a solid
predator movie predator redesign seemed
unnecessary but didn't bother me way
better than expected
the predator scene in prey lives up to
the species storied reputation the big
guy hunts and kills a rattlesnake a wolf
a bear a group of comanches and a whole
squad of french trappers in brutal
fashion these scenes offer some of the
best action of the entire predator
franchise as the alien baddie utilizes
an assortment of unique weapons and
abilities to take out his foes perhaps
that's why some fans were left feeling
short-changed at the monster's demise
following his trail of carnage the
hunter chases naru who stole his mask in
a previous scene into the forest and
eventually becomes stuck in some mud he
disappears below the surface but manages
to pull himself out of the trap long
enough to aim his arrow launcher at
naru's head unaware that the clever
warrior has placed his mask on a nearby
tree
this is as far as you go
no more
[Music]
this is it
our antagonist can only tilt his head in
confusion before an arrow streaks
through his skull killing him instantly
a twitter user noted the predator dies
in what i think is the dumbest way for a
predator to die it would be a badass
kill if he didn't stand there looking
all osh for a few good seconds
another complaint about prey among fans
is the predator's inability to kill a
young woman with minimal combat
experience one user made a composite
image of the entire cast of the original
predator film standing next to naru
indicating that it took an entire squad
of trained soldiers to take down the
original monster but only a single
inexperienced warrior to succeed in the
latest film one could argue the point of
naru's character arc is to show the
merits of brains over brawn and
outwitting an interstellar killing
machine that isn't convincing enough for
some including one twitter user who
states in this movie the predator one
punch kills a 1 000 pound grizzly but
can't strangle the 110 pound protag even
when it has its hand around her neck one
could also point out that a theme of the
entire original predator film is brains
over brawn dutch is the last one
standing because he realizes that the
combat experience and physical might of
his team are no match for the kind of
clever strategy that both he and naru
rely on in their climactic battles
prey is not a perfect film there's
plenty to love but this predator prequel
has some glaring issues notably the
wonky cgi many of the animals in the
movie look a little off especially
during the bear fight even fans who like
the film point out that some of the
visual effects in the sequence are
simply not up to modern blockbuster
standards one critic said a couple of
intro shots of the bear were not very
good later on when the bear and predator
were fighting was much much better but
you can tell they were like this part
doesn't matter all that much but this
next part will be in the trailer it was
a little rough another tweeted prey was
basically what if the power rangers
movie had very bad cgi though that same
user went on to praise the action scenes
overall they clearly had no love for the
distracting special effects
nauru is largely seen as a misfit by her
fellow tribesmen who don't support her
rebellious ways in fact except for her
brother tabe no one steps up to support
nauru or her quest to become a great
hunter
who invited you
we won't be gone long enough to need a
cook
but the understatement to this aspect is
one of the reasons some critics praised
prey with one noting a subtle approach
to the arc of nauru is appreciated as
the filmmakers rarely resort to forced
antagonism via the tribe's people to
make their point some fans don't agree
including the hosts of the angry movie
review who cite the scene in which one
of the men in nauru's tribe orders her
to go back to the village the critic
argues that while the explicit bullying
makes for easy conflict and also feels a
little dumbed down the others on the
show agreed feeling that while the
overall purpose of the scene was fine
the silly dialogue undercuts the tension
saying instead of hokey dialogue it
could have all been done in looks or
different ways just adult it up a little
bit
prey ends much like the original
predator with naru defeating the alien
hunter by utilizing her wits and
escaping with her life some have
complained that nauru should have been
roughed up a bit more during her battle
with the predator noting that even
arnold schwarzenegger was left bloodied
and broken at the end of the original
film one user makes a point that even
after she massacres the alien narut
doesn't have a mark on her they go on to
note that the team from predator had
difficulty bringing down the original
alien even with their high-tech weaponry
a reddit user stated that they enjoyed
prey but added that they missed how
clever the predator used to be they went
on to lament how the predators no longer
seem like much of a threatening presence
after a few movies that have seen them
be beaten with relative ease
an aspect of prey drawing criticism from
fans is the lack of memorable supporting
characters it's almost a tradition for
predator films to feature great
ensembles surrounding the central
protagonist in their battle with the
alien hunter
john mctiernan's original 1987 film
included the likes of carl weathers bill
duke sunny landom and jesse ventura
among others while latter sequels
arguably dipped in quality from the
original hit or missed tv host andrew
tate opined that even the lesser films
had solid supporting casts he argues
prey doesn't have supporting characters
other than the brother the lead
character's brother he's in it i thought
he was really good but he wasn't in it
enough there wasn't enough development
tate felt none of the deaths and prey
really mattered explaining
there's too many other characters that
get wiped out and i'm just like oh well
it's just another generic npc from
skyrim i don't care about them one 4 out
of 10 rating on imdb had a fairly
scathing review stating the comanche
people portrayed in the film have only
one thing to live for survival it also
makes it very hard for them to be
personable and likeable every character
in the film other than the main girl
might as well have been the exact same
person
one of arnold schwarzenegger's most
iconic one-liners comes from the
original predator
if it bleeds
we can kill it
the same line is repeated in prey by
nauru's brother tabe while they're both
tied to a tree during the battle
sequence with the french fur trappers
for some the moment was a
goosebump-inducing callback to predator
but others felt a bit of dialogue was
shoehorned into the film one tweet
described the line as being shoehorned
into prey for no reason in the comment
section below the tweet the user posited
it would have been better if they gave
one of billy's lines to them there's
something hunting us and it ain't no man
we're all gonna die and then they all
indeed die
about midway through prey nauru comes to
a startling conclusion while tied up to
a tree with her brother the predator
won't kill her because it doesn't see
her as a threat this ties into the
overall theme of prey naru is trying to
prove her worth to those around her
while many in her tribe see her is
little more than someone who needs to
learn her place however some fans were
angered by this twist in their negative
review of the film bad movie reviews
claimed the movie constantly panders to
gender politics as apparently in this
movie the predator isn't attacking the
female lead because it doesn't see her
as a threat since when does the predator
care about the gender of its victims in
the comment section for the same video a
user noted that the predator slaughtered
the fatally injured fur trapper raphael
despite knowing that he didn't have a
weapon and was physically hampered he
explains he certainly wasn't a threat
but that didn't stop the predator from
killing him others in the comments agree
with another user arguing don't let
anyone fool you predators have attacked
women with weapons in other movies only
exception was predator 2 where the woman
was pregnant and he didn't
in one particular way prey seems to be
messing with predator franchise lore
which is a bad idea when dealing with
hardcore fandom the character of rafael
attolini plays a huge part in the
franchise at least in terms of comic
books and spin-offs adelini was the name
inscribed on the gun given to danny
glover by one of the departing predators
at the end of predator 2 seemingly as a
sign of respect for years fans wondered
who this mysterious man was and why a
predator would carry around his weapon
clearly seeing it as some sort of prized
trophy to be handed off when vested in
combat as it turns out the answers lie
in a 1996 dark horse comic book titled
predator 1718 a storyline prey
completely ignores
instead the film features a man named
rafael who was killed by the predator
after handing his flintlock pistol to
naru while it's neat to see the predator
2 easter egg and pray the complete
disregard for previous comic book canon
has disappointed some much like disney's
retconning of pre-existing star wars
expanded universe stories
one of the coolest scenes in prey
features naru taking out a group of
french trappers using her throwing axe
and some well-timed flips chantal looked
like one long take the sequence is
violent gory and completely badass as
nauru slices and diced his enemies left
and right without remorse still there
were quite a few fans who decried the
moment as unbelievable a reddit user
noted that nauru was mostly seen as
useless by her tribe for much of the
film continuing
then when the movie calls for it she can
suddenly slaughter a camp of 10 or so
men in 45 seconds it would have been a
better step imo for her to have been a
capable hunter and warrior rather than
making her instantly go into beast mode
for the last 15 to 20 minutes
others have joked that nauru's abilities
are more akin to kiana reeves killer
assassin than john wick than a real-life
indigenous warrior one tweet jokes naru
pray is very obviously the founder of
the assassins guild and john wick the
obvious fact that john wick predator and
alien as a shared universe is basically
the greatest gift 2022 could have given
me
[Music]